[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast retro cold war edition episode
number
16 that's right 116 not a prime number
no danger of it in this case
um we've been off for a week we were uh
recalibrating and the world was also
recalibrating not in the best direction
but
anyway here we are um
we've accomplished something great all
of us
me the audience
well recently i don't know if it was our
last episode but recently we discussed
the fact that we had made it
halfway through the winter we are now
two-thirds of the way through the winter
it's looking ever more like we will
survive to see the spring yeah
unlike certain dinosaurs from 65 million
years ago yeah it's not looking good for
that i mean certain dinosaurs from 65
million years ago are doing not as well
as they have been but still still
hanging in there um but yeah the ones
you're referring to they uh they're not
going to make it yeah the non-uneven
dinosaurs they just uh they went out in
a puff of well i don't know rock and
rage or something a puff of magic dragon
um and it seems like it happened in the
spring which is kind of amazing like in
this in the sea of
ridiculousness out of which it is hard
to gather hope and inspiration uh
there's some research this week uh
suggesting that not only can we get you
know it's probably the chick's love
impact it might have been you know
there's the deck and traps in india
there's a couple of possible competing
hypotheses for what happened 65 million
years ago at the cretaceous tertiary
boundary when after which uh the
non-avian dinosaurs were gone and which
brought in the age of mammals
but some new research suggests that not
only can we get it to sort of that level
of precision
the event whatever exactly it was um but
that it was in the springtime
and i just i you know
i love science oh man i love frickin
science because we can we can tell
things at that kind of level of
precision in some cases
and use inference use a whole series of
inferences and when they are considered
with one another we say that looks ever
more likely
extinction in the spring
yeah yeah yeah that's something it is
amazing my guess is that that it's going
to be i mean i know nothing about this
i'm going to be putting you through your
paces as you explain oh well
this research but um
but i'm going to guess
that we have a pretty good shot at being
right about the season and no shot
whatsoever about being right about the
year
oh yeah yeah no for sure though this and
this of course doesn't
doesn't presume to get at the year the
the evidence that you would look at to
assess seasonality which is of course
going to have to do with uh
signals about growth rates and you know
when when growth is happening more and
therefore when certain kinds of uh
isotopes and other molecular forms are
being laid down in in bone such they can
be fossilized um it's really a totally
different kind of evidence than you know
how how many milli how many tens of
millions of years ago again was that
right and in its own way um
what difference does it make what exact
year it was on the other hand seasonally
speaking it does make a kind of an
interesting uh difference then so anyway
it's going to be i'm looking forward to
the point that we get to discuss yeah i
don't even i i don't know very much
about it so i've said most of what i
know but um let's do let's do
announcements and um and ads and then
get into
getting into the meat of the show um so
um
we
uh continue to be thrilled with uh the
responses that we continue to get about
the hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century it continues to there are a
number of um
number of translations into other
languages in the works at this point uh
with the first of them due in the spring
in the in french and um
and
we just
encourage you if you are interested in
the kinds of analysis that allows you to
clear away some of the chaff and get to
the wheat of
uh clear logical thinking we think that
we do a pretty good job of it and so do
many other people uh in this book hunter
gatherers guide to the 21st century yes
although oddly oddly this week
chaff has taken on its second meaning
which actually may be etymologically
related to the first meaning
is this a ukraine thing well kind of
yeah it's a spider jet thing
there is a kind of distraction that
planes drop in order to get missiles
that target them to blow up in the wrong
place sounds like at least it sounds
like the same
yes metaphorical traffic the wheat being
the plane the chaff being the stuff that
uh you can get the missiles to
to target indeed
um okay
we are live on youtube and honesty the
chat is on odyssey for those of you who
are live with us you can ask questions
which will happen in the second hour i
would imagine everybody who's with us is
live
i hope so yeah yeah i
i really i do i hope so i hope i hope
that our viewer count isn't being um
you know added to by by the dead
yes well they just do a poor job of
viewing i don't know we should we should
move on this is becoming depressing and
okay we don't need any more of that no
we don't uh you can ask your questions
at
www.darkhorse
that's questions for the q a uh if you
have logistical questions about um you
know how do i ask questions which this
would be a strange moment to need that
uh but you can uh email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
speaking of which our moderator
has received well over a hundred uh
a hundred emails of interest about uh
the uh web developer uh that we that we
sent out a call for a couple weeks ago
so we are we are
trying to make our way through those um
and uh are
thrilled with the level of response but
just recognize that there's a lot to get
through
uh you can go to
darkhorsepodcast.orgstore.darkor
to find
images of this little guy here this epic
tabby and
and digital book burning and direwolves
and various other things
at natural selections my substack i have
been focused on the trucker's convoy in
canada for
for many weeks now
and of course
what happened since we were with you
last
was first
trudeau announced that he was invoking
the emergencies act
uh and then
after quite a lot of um
quite a lot of drama
uh he
he sent in the police and they got rid
of the convoy
and um and then the emergencies act has
since been rescinded i'm not sure that's
exactly the right word but it is um he's
backed off of it basically he was he was
losing
um but he was losing in a way that can
be framed as winning which is so much of
what losing looks like these days
doesn't it yes the curtain fell on the
emergencies act i think that's the way
we should think of it okay good i hope
yeah i like that i like that anyway
there's a whole lot the this most recent
piece that i that i published on natural
selections is get ready for the get
ready for the biggest game of
whack-a-mole the world has ever seen
and i'm i'm hoping that happens that we
have lots of
basically um so many pop-up protests
that are objecting to
the mandates the tyranny the
authoritarianism
the
broad governmental overreach in times in
which we have been lied to endlessly
such that it becomes clear that actually
the power that they appear to be
wielding the majority they appear to
have
is is
very thin
and by that i don't mean like 51 i mean
it has the appearance of of depth and
robustness but i i think it is largely a
a potemkin
kind of uh village situation yeah it is
potemkin victory they pretend that they
are winning they are declaring victory
so that we will not notice how badly
they've botched this and have lost and
they have lost in large measure because
of the rate at which people are waking
up to their [ __ ] which is good news
it's late it's good but hopefully it's
not too late hopefully it's not too late
okay without well i don't usually clap
on air
okay um without further ado we have
three ad sponsors this week for which as
usual we are very grateful
our first one is sundays
excuse me
and and we got a little movement in the
background from our dog at the very
mention of sundays i found her with
sundays this morning and boy was she
thrilled she was leaping and dancing and
spinning and doing all the stuff she
does when we give her sundays which is
dry dog food how exciting could that
possibly be i can tell you exactly how
exciting really yes it's excellent stuff
excellent stuff okay best thing never
tasted do you like it better than for
instance the soup that i made this week
no comment i i'm very fond of the soup i
will say that within the category dog
food i am
most fond of sunday i did add uh sort of
a garden and some crunchies to the top
of the soup now it was nuts and sort of
roasted corn but uh maybe next time some
sundaes
please don't
all right
when sundays approached us about being a
sponsor we were dubious we have a
labrador right there in the corner um
she like all labs oh wow somehow she's
on that bed but you can't see her um
labs elite anything as anyone who's ever
met a lab will know what possible
difference was she's going to show an
interest between her usual kibble a
widely available high-end brand and
sundays we were wrong
maddie's loves the food that sundays
makes loves it is far better for her
than the standard burnt kibble that
provide that uh comprises most dried dog
food sundays is the first and only human
grade to whip human grade here air dried
dog food combining the nutrition and
taste of all natural human grade foods
with the ease of a zero prep ready to
eat formula sunday's is an amazing way
to feed your dog and in a pinch a person
too
sundays is easy for humans too no fridge
no prep no clean no preb what's prep ah
brett what's forever wow okay
exactly i will look it up after the
podcast there's no preb and there's also
no prep no cleanup no gross wet dog food
smells sunday's is gently air dried and
ready to eat no artificial binders
synthetic additives or general garbage
all of sunday's ingredients are easy to
pronounce except for quinoa and healthy
for dogs to eat i think quinoa is easy
to pronounce but hard to spell
yep in a blind taste test sunday's
outperformed leading competitors 40 to
0. it sounds like a made-up number i
know but here's the thing when i have a
bowl of maddie's previous food ready for
her she certainly is enthusiastic again
she's a lab but when i have a bowl of
sundaes ready for her as i did this
morning it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm do you want to make your dog
happy with her diet and keep her healthy
try sundays we've got a special deal for
our listeners receive 35 off your first
order go to sundays4dogs.com
darkhorse or use code darkhorse at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s
dot com forward slash dark horse switch
to sundays and feel good about what you
are feeding your dog
yes and i should just point out that if
you are in fact a dog following those
directions on the internet no one will
know it isn't your credit card
this is very true yes good
our second sponsor this week is moinc
m-o-i-n-k
less than two percent of americans are
farmers and their average on-farm income
is a loss of eight hundred dollars
that's why ninety percent of farmers
have an off-the-farm job
they feed america but can't feed their
own families that's why lucinda an
eighth generation farmer founded the
meat subscription box company moiq
that's moo plus oink oink
moiq delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and wild-caught alaskan
salmon direct to your door
moik farmers farm like our grandparents
did like my grandparents did and as a
result monk meat tastes like it should
which is to say delicious just four
companies control 80 percent of the us
meat industry and mink is helping family
farms become financially independent
outside of big agriculture support moinc
support family farming i love everything
about mike the fact that the meat is
grass-fed and finished and small farms
the lovely publications that come along
with it and of course the meat itself
which is truly delicious we've mentioned
that we had our thanksgiving turkey from
mike and then made stock out of it and
had soup for a long time after that from
that stock and we've had their steaks
and their sausages it's all delicious
keep american farming going by signing
up at mointbox.com darkhorse right now
and listeners of this show will receive
free filet mignon for a year that's one
year of the best filet mignon you'll
ever taste but for a limited time
spelled m o i n k
box.com let me try that again spelled
m-o-i-n-k-b-o-x dot com slash darkhorse
that's monkbox.com
darkhorse for
uh 35
nope
sorry uh for a year of the best filet
mignon for free with your first order
awesome yes all right
our final sponsor for the week is viva
barefoot
vivo barefoot are shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of what feet should be
and are constrained by usually that
someone doesn't actually know what feet
are about at all vivo barefoot in
contrast knows feet vevo barefoot isn't
driven by fashion
you can tell because the shoes aren't
really all that attractive until you've
put them on and realize that this is
what you should have looked like from
the beginning can i i'm going to
interrupt here and say that someone
approached me this week in a trader
joe's and said do you like those shoes i
said oh my god i love them even though
they're ugly she said oh i don't think
they're ugly see so there you go this is
the experience you put them on thinking
that's a funny looking shoe and then you
think all other shoes are funny looking
that's that's now how i feel about
regular shoes
um and i also when i put on regular
shoes i feel i feel like i have hooves
which is not ideal
it's not ideal no it's not so we love
these shoes they are beyond comfortable
the tactile feedback from the surfaces
you walk on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run barefoot but modern
shoes that are overly cushioned and
strangely shaped have negatively
impacted foot function
and are contributing to a health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt people barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 percent in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them the number of people wearing
vevo barefoot is growing it's an odd
little club easily recognizable
recognizable because the shoes are a
little unusual looking once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop go to
vivobarefoot.com darkhorse to get an
exclusive offer of 20 off additionally
all new customers get a hundred day free
trial so you can see if you love them as
much as we do that's
vevobarefoot.com v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t
dot com slash dark horse
and as usual we are grateful for our
sponsors yes indeed
there we go
our green perimeter off yes we can
remove the green perimeter parameter
would you say zach
okay all right we're good all right good
um i think you're gonna you're gonna
launch us i'm gonna launch this yes and
uh i must tell you that somehow this
week it all oddly comes together even
though the topics seem to have nothing
to do with each other
it would be wrong of us to launch into a
discussion of anything without noting
that somehow suddenly without warning
the 20th century is back the cold war is
afoot and we are now um grappling with
that reality which we probably didn't
need to but
because we have not been minding the
store
we have been reminded that there are
actually rules to this game and if you
do not pay attention to them they
they come at you fast
all right so
my hope today was to talk about a
hypothesis a hypothesis about
myocarditis and why it is being
triggered by mrna vaccines of the type
we have seen now i'm not going to
present this
as factual i do not know that this is
true
but what i do know is
that an understanding of
a bit of biology and understanding of
what viruses are about the predicament
that viruses put multicellular creatures
like us in
and the way that our ancestors have
evolutionarily learned to fend off
viruses suggests a hazard about this
new
and amazing but until now untested
technology
uh when introduced into the human body
so that's my hope and i think the thing
to do here is you're going to play
student and i don't mean student in the
sense that most people are familiar with
it i mean it in the sense that
we
scientists become each other's students
at the point that we have something to
discuss where
uh where we don't know right we are the
students of
of those who have seen something we have
not yet seen so you're going to play
that role on behalf of the
the audience which means
explicitly the expectation is that i
interrupt you when uh you say something
that i don't find clear or that i
uh maybe disagree with yeah maybe
disagree with and maybe i learned
something because you forced me to see
something about what i'm saying that i
didn't see when i went through it myself
um something like that okay and you know
of course the
lovely thing is that this is exactly how
we behaved in a classroom and we had a
group of
you know if we taught together something
like
50 students but we would also be each
other students in that context and
certainly we have different areas of
specialty and it all works out pretty
well because really what you always want
when you're trying to understand
something is somebody who understands
why you don't get something yet to ask
the question that causes it to be
explained in a way that you do get
and potentially model
what other people
may or may not already know
right that's so the difference between
say the dinner table
and a classroom is that the classroom is
going to be a representative sample of
at least you know some of something of
some larger group uh and uh you will
hear from people you know if you hear
from a few people that isn't making any
sense to me there's a decent chance that
either there's a there's a there's a
lack of understanding in the population
that you didn't know was there
there's a way that you're communicating
it that um
that is is in someone in in some number
of people's blind spots so let's you
know let's try this this is this is
tougher than either a dining room table
or your dinner table or a classroom
because the audience really is a lot is
all of you
who we can't hear we can't hear and we
don't know in detail so we can't even
guess what is in this unclear we hear a
little bit and in fact we'll end maybe
today with a with a one of so many
lovely notes that we got um in these
last couple of weeks from people um but
uh
but we can't hear in real time so anyway
and i would just say that there are
many many different
moves that the student in this case is
entitled to avail themselves of
including you know here's a question i
don't think the
i don't think the audience will know x
piece i think i know it but i'm going to
ask you the question anyway to get you
to spell it out so
anyway the
yeah you you have tools
i don't know what you just did was
rhetorical if you're about to now ask me
something no okay that was rhetorical
that was just pointing out okay um that
i am not necessary in explaining this to
you i am really using you as a surrogate
for people most of whom aren't
biologists and so anyway i'm going to
err in the direction of being overly
clear hopefully
all right so
here's the predicament
viruses i believe i'm going to
oversimplify everything because that's
what we do
in science especially anything in the
area of complex systems the fact is we
do not fully understand biology we're a
long way away so what we do when we
discuss biology
is we describe a cartoonish version of
the reality and hopefully our cartoon is
simplified but not incorrect right we
described an overly simple version of
the reality and hopefully if you were to
expand it to the full level of
complexity it wouldn't contradict what
you say that's the objective
so i'm going to describe enough about
viruses and enough about the immune
system for you to see a picture that i
think i increasingly see
clearly right that may explain
why myocarditis is a downstream effect
of rna vaccinations
or at least some of them
and
in so saying i do not mean that this is
the only reason right we have different
kinds of hypotheses you've got mutually
exclusive hypotheses where if this is
causing it then that isn't causing it
but in this case i'm just simply saying
here is one mechanism that i believe is
likely to create a link between these
things and there may be others okay let
me um ask you right up off the bat then
you are see you are going to propose a
hypothesis uh that posits an explanation
for why myocarditis is downstream of
these mrna
vaccinations of course we now know that
myocarditis is one of the sometimes
effects of um go of sarcoby2 infection
of the actual disease covid
is this a separate hypothesis from that
uh and if so do you for it does does
this explain that separately and if so
do you have a separate explanation for
why you think uh cysco v2 may also be uh
causing myocarditis so i will so
myocarditis my understanding of it and
i'm not a heart specialist by any means
um
my understanding of it is that it is
effectively
inflammation of the heart muscle and
inflammation can be downstream of
various other processes now my guess and
i do not know but my guess
is that the inflammation caused by covid
is different in origin than the
inflammation caused by
the um
by the mrna vaccines and i believe i
have learned this by listening to dr
mccullough who is a cardiac specialist
and i should also point out
as i was
realizing as i was formulating
my hypothesis for what's going on here i
shared it with several people
and
one of those people
alexandros morenos said i believe i have
heard that hypothesis elsewhere and he
in fact pointed me to a place where dr
mccullough appears to um to spell it out
and i also now know that our friend
jonathan cui who some of you will know
from his
lab league series early
in the pandemic called jc on a bike
journal club on a bike
that he also has advanced a version of
this hypothesis so i don't claim it to
be unique i do think i arrived at it
independently
but
in any case here here's the basics
we multicellular creatures
have a problem with pathogens and
pathogens come in different flavors
right you've got things like fungi a
comparatively rare pathogen for us
bacteria a comparatively common pathogen
for us and viruses a very common
pathogen now you want to compare in your
mind the difference between bacteria and
viral
infections
bacteria are living creatures
and as such they have a biology of their
own it is simplified relative to us
eukaryotes
right
because bacteria are smaller and simpler
than we are but nonetheless they are
biological creatures in their own right
viruses
are
an interesting kind of exception they
function biologically but they are
definitionally on in a gray area and the
reason for that is that viruses have
abandoned
the
mechanisms that allow a biological
creature to function now how is it that
they function if they've abandoned those
mechanisms
well they borrow those mechanisms so
they are in some sense
analogous to
special forces that you might drop
behind enemy lines that would not carry
a great deal of equipment with them but
would have the
the knowledge of how to utilize
stuff that they find
inside of enemy territory for their own
use so instead of
you know getting tanks and airplanes and
things in behind enemy lines you you
drop something that is full of
information about how to utilize what
they find locally to the same effect and
viruses are effectively this they have
gotten a tremendous advantage by
abandoning their own biology and
commandeering the biology of the
creatures that they infect once they
invade right
and
what this means is that we have a
problem in trying to fight them because
almost everything that viruses do isn't
really them it's our own machinery that
has been commandeered and has now been
turned against us okay can i interject
here please um
just uh just a point of clarification
which i think is not at all central to
your argument but um i believe and i
think i may have missed something but i
believe that you said
pathogens can come in the form of sort
of fungus and bacteria and viruses and
it seems to me that fungus is a really
tiny tiny kind of human pathogen but
there's two large classes that aren't
included in that so just just in service
of sort of categorizing what kinds of
human pathogens there are there are of
course
single-celled eukaryotic
pathogens like plasmodium which is the
um the
microbe that causes malaria yeah um so
you know bacteria are single-celled
prokaryotes without without a new cell
nucleus and then there are single-celled
eukaryotes what used to be called
protists i think but it's sort of a
giant giant junk group you know it
doesn't have a single evolutionary
origin and then of course there are um
multicellular
organisms animals like like weren't
worms sure right um so just just to just
to have like a categorization your
pathogens come in all all of these
single-celled multi-cell all of these
things um the distinction really that i
think you're trying to make here is
virus versus not virus right where you
know the virus and you know there are
lots of other
functional ways of discriminating
between them but the particular
distinction that you're making
is because a virus has stripped itself
of almost all biological functioning
um it can act as effectively special
forces yep right um it can it can come
in
um and i mean you didn't say this yet
but you've said this to me before it can
come in sort of like the dude with the
backpack and sneak in uh without having
all of you know it doesn't have a tank
and it doesn't have you know all the
stuff that makes it easy for the body in
this case to say ah there it is there it
is it's easy for it to sneak in under
under the wire and and without
alarming the self-defense okay so i want
to add two things one there's even a
weirder category than virus we now know
this is something that was very much
learned during our lifetimes which is
that there's also something that's even
more stripped down which is a prion
disease and it's not even really clear
that a prion disease
it's not clear that it's serving its own
interests a prion disease is a
contagious
misfolding of proteins right and so
anyway that's very it's very pathogenic
from the point of view of doing harm
spongiform encephalopathy being you know
mad cow disease being a classic example
of this but you know a virus is at least
creature-like in the sense that we know
what it's trying to accomplish a prion
disease could just be
an error that
echoes right
i'm not going to pretend to know i'm
sure there are people who know better
than i do but
nonetheless the spectrum goes from
things like a worm right which is
similar to us a multicellular uh
creature to single-celled creatures to
non-celled creature-like things viruses
to
folding errors right yeah and all of
these things have have pathological
implications
um but let's take your example of the
special forces guy who parachutes behind
enemy lines let's say he gets a tank he
gets behind enemy lines he sneaks up
behind somebody who's got a tank slips
his throat and takes over the tank right
now you've got a question which is your
own forces are now looking at a tank
that looks like them that's our tank
but it's it's pointing at us right
so the point is which tanks of ours do
we now shoot at right and that is the
question that viruses create and so
without going too deeply into the issues
of immunity
the overarching story of immunity for
creatures like us
is something called self versus non-self
recognition
what happens is early in development
there is a process in which your immune
system which in principle is capable of
responding to effectively any
biological molecule that immune system
is asked a question before you encounter
the outside world and the question is
which things can you currently see
now if during that period you know in
utero you see molecules that are
biological well then okay those are
yours right they almost have to be right
because you're insulated from the
outside world and so well they're yours
they're moms well but that's just the
thing even that the placenta is a
absolutely remarkable organ that does
not get enough attention right the way
in which it allows mother and baby's
systems to interact without exchanging
very much uh above a certain size is
miraculous
but the point is the
self-non-self-recognition system is
programmed during development to
recognize all of the stuff that you
yourself produce and then to go on for
the rest of your life and ignore it
right
then once you build a system that
recognizes all of the molecules you
produce and ignores them
now it can do something else which is
now anytime it sees anything that isn't
on the ignore list it can assume it's a
pathogen right
that means that you don't need to have
seen a particular pathogen before in
order to know to fight it right right so
it's a simple rubric that can be gamed
that can be gamed and also has certain
failure modes like allergy
right so if pollen gets into your lungs
well your immune system won't recognize
it as self but it's not a pathogen and
so fighting it can be worse than
ignoring it but you don't know that it's
actually should be on the ignore list
and
there's lots of interesting stuff about
the the ige system ig is the
abbreviation for antibodies which are
the most famous component of this system
which we know which has also allowed our
minds to be gamed but
nonetheless ige
is one of the subsets of antibodies that
appears to be particularly prone to
create allergic reactions and it's
probably particularly prone to create
allergic reactions because it's not busy
doing the things that it would normally
do like fight worms which we don't have
a problem with in the first place
because we have such a sterile landscape
that we've created for our bodies and
our environments right so you've got
some part of your immune system that's
twiddling its thumbs and it overreacts
to you know yeah it's it's the bank's
grass ball and it's grass balling right
i could just sit down just relax we got
this it's grass but okay so
you've got a system and it functions
basically by
ignoring everything that you make and
therefore
feeling entitled to react to anything
that you don't like
now again remember what viruses are
viruses are these um
they are like
particles with a creature like objective
but no creature like bits right it's
just like an envelope with creature-like
objective written on the letter inside
and that letter if it gets into your
cells instructs the cells to do what the
virus if it were a creature would do for
itself right make more viruses
so here's the here's the thing
when viruses get into us wherever that
happens if they're respiratory viruses
it will typically be in the surface of
the lungs for example
you know we get other kinds of viruses
it'll be in other tissues but the virus
gets in if it manages to get into a cell
enough that its message can trigger the
cell to start doing the virus is bidding
rather than the the creatures bidding
then that
cell
becomes effectively a factory
that is dedicated to the viruses
interests
now
the body has to now look at this the
same way you would look at a tank that
had been commandeered by enemy forces
that had parachuted over your border and
grab the tank right it has to say aha i
used to think that was self but i gotta
that one drives different right that one
drives on the left side of the road not
the right side of the road or something
i gotta shoot at that one as if it's the
enemy because it actually is
even though it also has the tags that
say self right it has the tags that say
self but it has
indicators that it is not anymore self
and so
the basic punch line here is that
when
our body sees a cell
that
looks like us
but does something extra in other words
it puts out messages that look like
non-self
it concludes
that is a virally infected cell and the
right thing to do is then to kill it
because a virally infected cell is not
going to become unvirally infected so
there's no trade-off like how much is
that cell worth to me
uh you know dead versus alive the point
is once it's been commandeered even
though losing a cell is not a good thing
it's better than that cell continuing to
do the enemy's bidding
so the immune system targets cells and
in fact the cells themselves have an
interest in being targeted
because
they only pass on their genes if the
creature survives and the creature
survives better if it's not infected so
the cell effectively would volunteer for
death
um okay
but the basic point is what does a
virally infected cell look like it looks
like a weird hybrid between self and
non-self right it has self markers
because it's a self cell and it has
foreign markers because it its internal
machinery has been commandeered and it's
now making proteins that the body has
never seen before etc etc
okay
so
now what happens if you
do what these mrna vaccines do right if
you just assume that they function as
the brochure tells you that they should
these vaccines
contain a message they are viral like in
this way they contain a message without
biological structure around it and it is
encoded or it is uh it is it's even more
stripped down than the virus itself yeah
it is a single message in this case
these are cartoonishly simple vaccines
in the sense that they produce one
antigen the spike protein
and that spike protein
is wrapped in lipid nanoparticles now
why is it lipid nanoparticles it's lipid
nanoparticles because like dissolves
like and by surrounding these things in
lipids they are protected from the parts
of the
human system that would disassemble
the mrnas is i'm not sure how to dance
that but um uh that are in the intra
intercellular space would
immediately tear apart the mrna if it
weren't protected right so by putting it
in this envelope they make it invisible
to a system that would otherwise attack
it as foreign and they also cause it to
have an affinity for human cells those
human cells all cells are covered in
this lipid envelope and so because light
dissolves like
the lipid
and this is one of these places where
the story retail isn't exactly right the
lipids being nonpolar are not actually
attracted to each other but they're
driven together by all the polar stuff
sticking to itself
so well on the lipids on the cells
actually this phospholipid bilayer which
has
things sticking inside which
yeah yeah anyway so the point is
the lipid coat the lipid nanoparticle
coat causes the mrna
to get taken up by cells and those cells
of the way the cells are constructed so
the con cells are constructed they have
a nucleus that has their normal human
cells normal human cells they have a
nucleus with a
dna genome in it
certain
mrnas are produced
from genes that the cell wants to
transcribe
and
they're produced from genes that the
cell wants to transcribe those mrna
messages move from inside the nucleus
into the cytoplasm and in the cytoplasm
you have ribosomes that automatically
translate mrnas that they encounter so
the whole clever thing about these
vaccines and it is truly clever
is if you put an mrna message into the
cytoplasm of a cell the cell
automatically transcribes it because the
cell is built to do that because it
wouldn't encounter mrnas in its
cytoplasm other than in the case of
maybe being infected it's the factory
behind enemy lines
uh if you know if the virus is the enemy
and the virus is dropping in you're like
okay can we get
can we get
self to make
things that look like used to trigger
the immune system to say aha now i know
and once informed i will not forget
right okay so you get cells they pick up
the mrna from the vaccine they start
producing spike protein now the design
of these vaccines right the spike
protein has been modified
the hope of that modification which
failed actually so it doesn't completely
do this but presumably it dues it does
it somewhat modified from the so-called
wild type sorry scooby too right yeah so
it's been
modified in a couple ways the uh
it's got a hinged piece that's been
locked open
in order to expose
a piece of the antigen to the immune
system that would otherwise be so that
because the virus is a very sneaky
evolved creature it's covered in sugars
basically that shield what would
ordinarily trigger the immune system
from seeing the spike protein so they've
locked it open so the immune system sees
it but anyway the point is they put in
this anchor domain
to get these spike proteins to stick out
of the surface of the cells the hope
being that the immune system will see
these antigens sticking off the surface
of the cells will learn what they look
like and you will magically become
immune to the pathogen when it shows up
with very similar antigens on its
surface immunomagically immunomagically
well well said okay here's the problem
a cell
that is
displaying
the spike protein on its surface
will
look in all probability to the immune
system like an indication that that cell
has been virally infected because that
cell is now displaying a mixture of self
and non-self
proteins
and the immune system has no model for
this because the only time that that
would likely take place under natural
circumstance is viral infection the
right response to a cell that is doing
that is to kill it because as much as
that cell is useful it has been lost
right if your enemy has captured a tank
of yours you're better off even though
that was your tank
you're better off destroying it because
at the moment it's working for the enemy
and not you
so the immune system seeing cells that
have taken up the lipid nanoparticles
and transcribed the message inside the
right response for the immune system is
that is a virally infected cell and it
has to go
right now this is the wrong thing if you
could
tell the body what was really going on
what you would want to say is look stand
down the immune system
because that cell that looks like it has
been permanently compromised has only
been temporarily compromised those mrna
messages will eventually be lost and the
cell will go back to doing its own
bidding which is not something that
happens in a virally infected cell
so
the immune system reacts it overreacts
right and it destroys these cells now
the problem is and this this is where
this whole set of questions that we've
been dealing with over the course of
covid interacts with all the weird stuff
i did as a graduate student surrounding
telomeres and
cancer and
and tumors
the heart
is a weird tissue
now the reason that the heart is a weird
tissue
is that the heart does not have
normal repair capacity almost all of
your tissues have the capacity to
replace dead cells with
new cells and to keep functioning it
always comes at a cost because you're
always borrowing
from the future capacity to repair that
tissue and maintain it so every time you
destroy some tissue and have to replace
it you're effectively accelerating your
aging
but the heart is super special it's one
of a small number of tissues it doesn't
do that trick and what that means is
that when you destroy a cell in the
heart it doesn't get replaced by a
similar cell right
this is maybe too far afield but it
strikes me that the heart not having
repair capacity
is um
for analogous reasons to
salmon being symbol paris
that it is about
the chances
of
surviving repair or in the case of
salmon the chances of surviving another
trip back out to the ocean and years and
another move back into the
into the freshwater where you came from
and having another reproductive
opportunity
the chances in both of those cases are
so low
that in the case of the heart the repair
capacity has been dialed all the way
down um and in the case of salmon um
they've become a you know breed once
then die
species well interesting i think there's
an analogy i think it is actually
different but if i can it's a different
analogy yeah if i can rephrase what
you've said there's a point at which
your likelihood of making it to a second
reproductive event is so low if you're a
salmon if you're a salmon or really if
you're anything there's a point at which
if you are at reproduction
your chances of getting back to
reproduction are so low that you ought
to invest everything in that
reproductive event that you've reached
and therefore there's a shift where it's
like anything you anything you hold back
is wasted in all probability so you
might as well invest it all here that is
to say any tissue that you can turn into
more eggs or more sperm is better spent
now because it's very unlikely to get
back to this very difficult place yeah
specifically pacific salmon we're
talking about yeah
right and so anyway um yeah there's a
whole interesting discussion here i have
hypothesized that actually bears may be
the difference it could also be the
sharpness of the western mountains but
the point is the the
stakes are very different in the west
uh part of north america than the east
in a way that has caused
all but one of our western
salmon to go
semol paris
yeah
okay
so back to the heart why is the heart a
different case than the salmon case yeah
the hypothesis i put forward in my paper
with debbie seasick in i guess it was
published in 2002 finally that's right
the hypothesis that we put forward was
the reason that the heart lacks this
capacity
is that in order to have the capacity to
do cellular repair
you run the risk of creating what we
called a prototumor a prototumor is a
growth of cells if a cell becomes
unregulated oh yes and it produces a
bunch of you know if a cell becomes deaf
to the messages that say stop dividing
then it will just simply divide
and if a cell does that in the heart it
could create a prototumor let's imagine
something the size of a p
well a growth the size of a p if it
happens in your liver you're never going
to know about it if it happens on your
skin it will be a mole if it happens in
your heart it could block an artery and
kill you right so the point is the
danger of a prototumor is so high and
again this is a hypothesis i don't know
if it's true and as far as i know it's
never been tested but the danger of a
growth of cells out of place in the
heart is so large that
the system
has had repair turned all the way down
so that there is no hazard of that and
as a result the heart is this
absolute marvel of design or as if
design
where it goes for
85 100 years
effectively flawlessly without the
capacity for repair and there will be
people saying there is capacity for
prayer yeah there may be a tiny bit in
general though instead of repair what
you get is the capacity to scar right
and scar
is basically like
biology's speckle
right it's not the thing that is being
replaced it's something that's good
enough
um
and so in any case
to make a long story shorter here
you've got
an mrna message which causes cells to
transcribe or to translate a protein
that is not self
which almost cannot help but be read by
the immune system as an indication that
those cells have been virally infected
which they haven't been
but the immune system doesn't know about
mrna vaccines
and so it will assume
that the category that explains this
anomaly is infected cell and it will do
what the right thing to do is which is
to destroy that cell when in fact the
right thing to do here is to leave that
cell alone let the mrna messages burn
themselves out and let the cell go back
to its job
because damaging the heart is not a good
idea right damaging the heart is not a
good idea
i think one of the pieces i see missing
yet is um
obviously it was hoped it was expected
we were told that
uh
the mrna vaccines would stay basically
local to the spot of injection
and it is well documented at this point
that that has not happened
uh is the idea
that
they spread and maybe they are
predictable maybe maybe we could make
predictions with regard to you know
whether or not uh the proper aspiration
happened you know whether or not it was
left or right arm you know a number of
these things have been proposed um where
it will spread to or
um is the prediction that that um the
the
vaccine is going to be spreading
throughout the body um much to the
chagrin of those who develop the
vaccines uh and
that doesn't have necessarily widespread
horrible effects except when
it ends up in the heart it's not that it
is specifically going to the heart it's
that it's ending up everywhere which it
never was intended to do and when it's
up at the heart that's going to have
particularly bad effects yeah it's it's
in
i if the hypothesis is correct it is a
close analogy for what i found to be
likely with respect to drug toxicity
back in the days of my telomere work
which is right we see the heart damage
for a couple of reasons one because the
heart is very bad at self-repair so
damage shows up in a meaningful way
the same amount of damage in most other
tissues would never bother us right
you'd get better and you wouldn't know
that you'd lost some future capacity for
repair
and b
the failure of the heart is utterly
unambiguous right so let's say that the
vaccine
robs you of a bunch of liver capacity
well good news you were born with excess
liver capacity and so the point is
probably you don't die of liver failure
you die of something else so probably
you got away with it
right if it's the heart
well you probably didn't get away with
it you've borrowed from something
important right heart failure is one of
the major so you've got basically two
important uh biotic ways to die for a
well-fed well-protected creature one of
them has to do with uh
growth of tissues that shouldn't grow
basically tumors and cancers and the
other has to do with the failure of
organs that are necessary and heart
being primary among the organs that are
likely to fail and kill you and the
point is when this happens in somebody
young
it's conspicuous because it doesn't
happen in somebody young under ordinary
circumstances so when somebody drops
dead on the football pitch
that
catches our attention now it's not that
that never happens under normal
circumstances but there's a question
about is it happening more
than we're used to and is there a reason
for that and
basic
point here is that you've got
a mechanism of action the the expected
mechanism of action the desired
mechanism of action
is for this message to be taken up by
cells and and translated into protein
that is likely to trigger
the biological phenomenon of
and the de facto conclusion of the
immune system this is an infected cell
and it needs to be killed
when that happens in the heart it is
both
worse for you because your heart's not
good at dealing with it and more
conspicuous to medical science because
somebody who shouldn't have had a heart
attack just did right
and that that is resulting in this now
you raise an interesting point about
the
potential asymmetry
and this is this is one of the little
corollary hypotheses here which is that
um
if this is true if this is the mechanism
or one of the mechanisms that is causing
serious myocarditis to come to people
who have been vaccinated with these mrna
vaccines
there's a question about whether or not
what is it that causes it to be taken up
by the heart right the thing that is
lacking in these vaccines right if these
vaccines were really to be
brilliant enough to be
wielded in this way
they might have a targeting mechanism
that would cause them to be taken up
only by tissues that you could afford
to suffer this fate right and not to be
taken up by tissues that you very
definitely wanted to protect from it
like the heart and they don't have that
they've got no targeting mechanism in
that all in them at all so what they are
do what happens is you have a
um an arbitrary
uptake right it's not random because
some cells are more prone to take up the
mrna uh they have lipid nanoparticles
than others and the heart as i
understand it is prone to take them up
so if they flow to the heart first if
they escape the
the arm
and they flow to the heart
then that's a very likely place for them
to be taken up and then what you'll end
up with is dead tissue in the heart that
then
hopefully scars over and hopefully you
close to get away with it but you're
losing capacity from your heart for life
but
there's all kinds of questions if this
is actually true and again it's just a
hypothesis but if it's actually true
then it raises all kinds of questions
about what
how might we have vaccinated people that
would reduce this effect right so for
example
should you be getting this one in the
arm would you be better off getting this
shot in the ass right it's possible that
the circulatory pattern would be less
devastating because the stuff would get
taken up before it gets to your heart
now i don't know enough about
circulation to say maybe it would make
things worse if they gave it to you in
the butt cheek but
um
but
that's one possibility another
possibility is that there's asymmetry in
the circulatory system right heart
attacks cause left arm
pain and so there's a question
um we don't know because we didn't get
this vaccine but it's possible that they
sit you down they say which arm would
you like this and it's possible that
that shouldn't be your choice that they
should give it to you in the arm that
protects your heart better right so
anyway there are all kinds of questions
you could ask here
and
because what we've been fed is oh these
things are safe
we can't you know
john campbell did a marvelous uh
exploration of the question of
aspiration
right it's possible that you know it's
possible these vaccines are simply not
safe enough to do this but they could be
rendered a lot safer than they are by
things like aspiration technique by
uh tissue in which they are injected
and that we aren't asking those
questions because instead we've been fed
a fairy tale about safety right
all right um
so i think that's all i had to
to say
on this topic i just wanted to put the
hypothesis out there about why we might
be seeing this effect from these
vaccines and what it implies and you
know god forbid this happens to us again
what we might do better
indeed
um
i think uh
i think i thought that you also uh
wanted to talk a little bit about
um
why the origin of the virus matters with
regard to gain of function research
but before you do that
if if you do indeed want to talk about
that
this might be a
decent place to
point this out so i mean what what we've
been hearing from
all the public health officials
uh at this point now that they're
finally beginning to uh grant that
uh that their randomized control trials
were too short that they were indeed
shorter even than they were supposed to
be
uh that the efficaciousness
uh that was supposedly demonstrated in
them was not quite exactly and in many
ways not at all what it was that we were
told it was
but specifically with regard to safety
increasingly the tune has changed right
the tune is no longer of course
um of course we did everything that we
always do
um because it's become totally clear
that they didn't um
as so uh in octage october of 2021
norman deutsch published this excellent
piece and tablet at like a three or four
part i don't remember what um called
needle points uh which explores what he
calls vaccine hesitancy that's the term
that is used i don't i don't like it but
um and it's really it's really
extraordinary and uh he also read it
aloud on jordan peterson's podcast for
those who would prefer to to read it um
but here in
and a pdf of all of the pieces together
is available so here's a 38-page
document that is available if you go to
tablet i'll link there but here's just a
pdf
of it um
three two thirds of the way through or
half the way through
deutsche writes still it was obvious as
early as the fall this would have been
sorry i think this is going to be fall
of 2020.
still it was obvious as early as the
fall that some testing steps would be
skipped
we'll have less safety testing than we
typically would have gates noted we just
don't have the time
and
um
you know it
that's that's bill gates who said that
he was certainly not the only one of the
people pushing the one solution for the
massive problem that we are all sharing
uh but it's uh so you know his words are
not unique in this regard but
they are
telling because this is a rhetorical
trick that is becoming the thing that is
used against us
of you know first first there's the
lying the obfuscation you know of course
we did everything according to protocol
of course these are totally safe of
course we know
and then if and only if enough people in
the public are going like you know what
you couldn't possibly have here's how i
know and they are forced to reveal that
actually there were safety
steps skipped
or um or fudged or whatever it is
then the story we get is
well of course we did
a you know no acknowledgement that they
had just lied to you of course we did of
course we skipped some safety but it's
necessary because this is an emergency
and so this is just like
freaking trudeau invoking the
emergencies act against a bunch of
people who were standing up for their
freedoms right
and this is this is this is like almost
all of the rhetoric that we get back
when we resist now and so before you
i'm gonna step out outside of this
particular conversation for a moment to
go to something that seems completely
other
um
but it uses the same it uses exactly the
same rhetorical trick
and
this is on an issue um about which
um
you know we we actually do feel that
there is something that needs to be done
and reasonable people do disagree this
is going to be about climate change
reasonable people do disagree and this
is not about you have to accept the
science as if the science is a thing
but
we are so often told
that because climate change is the
emergency just like the code pandemic is
the emergency
it is okay
if we skip certain things like burden of
proof like scientific evidence and go
forward with the one solution that's
been proposed this is anti-scientific
it's anti-democratic it's pro-tyranny
it's all you know all of the bad things
and here's just a particular example
so we have um
here's an article zach if you just show
my screen briefly and then i'll pull my
screen back uh this is um
science science news so uh about about
some work that's being done it's not
published it's not some research that's
being published in science but about
work being done by a biotech firm the
headline is and this is from uh the 23rd
of february 2022 to fight climate change
a biotech firm has genetically
engineered a very peppy poplar
okay
um and it's you know it's it's a
in the voice that we have now come to
expect from
science journalism even at one of the
two premier science journals in the
world that's very much rah-rah this is
this is this is not journalism this is
advocacy one
and uh if i may have my screen back zach
so that i can just see what i wanted to
read what quotes i wanted to read here
um
we have in the article
um the the transgenic trees are growing
fast and the idea is that faster growth
means faster take-up of carbon dioxide
and therefore that's going to slow down
climate change that's the that's the
basic argument
um quote the firm's genetically enhanced
poplars grew more than 1.5 times faster
than unmodified ones in lab trials
uh and
there's a lot to say about what's wrong
with this research and and and we can go
there
but we have a quote from a forest
geneticist at oregon state university
who uh yes does in fact have a financial
stake in this outcome being what he
hopes it is so
there isn't even the pretense that
there's not uh financial incentives here
quote from the article strauss for one
believes the urgency of addressing the
climate crisis outweighs potential risks
associated with transgenic trees
we don't have the luxury he says to wait
for 30 years and make sure nothing can
possibly go wrong
oh really
transgenic trees yes no they've they've
generated uh
what look i mean they sound like a bunch
of dumb shits and so probably they
didn't do the work right and that's
probably what will protect us from their
madness but it sounds to me like what
they tried to do was create a really
impressive invasive species as if we
don't have a tragic invasive species
problem on virtually every continent
right and i mean
you know they bemoan in this article how
there are rules in place that prevent if
you're going to be um
be used as a sustainable forest project
you can't
product rather you can't be genetically
modified it's like okay has is anyone in
this biotech firm noticed what actually
naturally occurring fast-growing trees
true so let's take alder let's take
zakropia let's take a chroma balsa right
like just to name three of the world's
most known and widespread fast-growing
trees what is true of all of them they
grow fast they die young right they fall
over
very quickly they're light because they
are more air than structure because they
grew fast because that's what they do
yeah there are trade-offs that can't be
avoided yes or or let's take uh
eucalyptus right which is absolutely
devastating uh don't think it's
particularly fast growing well it's
particularly invasive and to the extent
that they've done their work at all well
to the extent that they are um
correct in at least arguing that this
would capture a bunch of carbon out of
the atmosphere then surely what they are
saying is that these are dense trees
right they have to be dense in order for
that to work right if they are you know
like sucropia mostly hollow so just
secropia is actually the one that i
mentioned that may not be familiar to
people it's just it's it's uh it is the
uh
[Music]
first primary success yeah the primary
successional species um in uh in lowland
tropical and lowland near tropical
forest along with along with balsa
although a lot of people will know that
balsa wood you know basically doesn't
have as many molecules right you could
like you can take super light you get
you know you can get the like mini
dimensional lumber in terms of boss of
wood to build stuff and you know unless
it's unless it's like
a half by half inch like you can just
squish it right it's because it's that
soft wood because fast growing means
soft wood right in general let's say
that they've got you know the equivalent
of eucalyptus which is a very dense
hard wood right but nonetheless they're
talking about i don't think eucalyptus
is fast growing but
um eucalyptus has a different fast to
capture
habitat
right but i mean it's got it's got a
number of different tricks up its sleeve
yep right it's you know it it withstands
fire for instance yes it means it starts
but anyway look the point the point is
and i and we're you're going to have to
work our way back here but one of the
the sort of themes of what we're getting
at which is actually going to link a
bunch of different things together uh
including uh
this will sound wrong but even the uh
appalling thing that has now taken place
in ukraine
is that in effect
we have a system in which everybody
who's supposed to be telling us what we
need to know has been
transmuted by
our economic system into a [ __ ]
salesman which is to say a liar right
and sometimes they do this by lying to
themselves i mean what salesman right is
going to invest in the precautionary
principle in which they're telling you
all of the reasons that actually you
shouldn't be listening to them because
the danger that they've missed something
is so great right or
a deep investigation
of the trade-offs where that salesman is
now going to tell you all the downsides
of the cool thing that they just tried
to convince you that you need to do and
in fact what they do instead
is they
hijack your amygdala or whatever it is
and they utilize your fear to get you to
stop thinking
right and that is what they have done in
all of these cases they've said we don't
have time the emergency is too great and
therefore you're going to have to let us
get you out of this dangerous situation
that you will otherwise suffer from yeah
and it's it's monstrous it's like
amygdala spinal tap
this one goes to 11 and we're going to
keep it at 11 on you for as long as we
can and we're going to make sure that
you buy our stuff right that you buy our
stuff and the fact is this is sort of
how you and i ended up in the crazy
position that we're now in right because
the fact is you can actually check their
claims and you can't check them like no
that's wrong but you can check them like
actually that doesn't add up what you
just told me has a flaw in it somewhere
and it's either here or it's there and
here's how you know and so
at the beginning of all of this at the
beginning of covid
you and i were hearing claims that you
know these vaccines are safe and
effective and it's like well well at the
beginning of cover we weren't because
you didn't exist you're in yeah okay
well i can tell you one thing right away
you're lying when you say it's safe
because safe you know i can't tell you
that there's a harm but i can tell you
you don't know anything about what this
does to you five years 10 years 20 years
down the road you couldn't it hasn't
existed long enough and so you're
telling me that it's safe is you
either admitting that you don't
understand what you're saying or that
you're willing to mislead me but either
way i'm now going to be super cautious
because i know that you're not telling
me the truth
now i want to point something out
we've got
various mantras that we use little
things that we say to flag certain kinds
of errors right like you know trade-offs
are a key thing for us because if you're
not talking about the trade-offs and
these things the chances are you're
involved in a sales pitch you're not
involved in a cost-benefit analysis yeah
the cost benefit of the analysis
requires the trade-offs we also say
welcome to complex systems and by that
what we mean is you are now dealing with
a realm so complex
that as soon as you tell me you know all
of the effects of the thing that you've
just proposed if the thing you've just
proposed is sufficiently novel you don't
know all the effects and the one thing
you can say to make me more comfortable
with you is we don't know all the
effects and if you don't say that then
the point is then the question is well
what did you miss and here i don't know
if you noticed this this this week
but i believe the 25th of february
a swedish paper
emerged
that actually upended a lot of the stuff
that um
some of our antagonists have crowed
about
very subtly and what it said and this is
this is a single paper maybe it's wrong
it's a single paper that demonstrated
something in vitro that is to say not in
living creatures but in
tissues outside of living creatures what
it showed
was
that um
the
vaccines the mrna vaccines actually get
reverse transcribed into dna which is
then found in the nucleus
of liver cells
o is right now
it isn't 100 clear what that means the
one thing that you would love to know
above all else which they did not show
in this paper was that it gets that it
does or does not get
basically spliced into the genome right
right which is a crucial question right
but they did show interestingly
that the fact of this mrna getting
uh reverse transcribed into dna which is
the language of the genome
then up regulates
a appallingly named protein something
like line one i mean god biologists i
love biologists
but they suck at naming things and this
is a particularly
bad case of that
that
failure on their part but anyway it up
regulates
the very machinery that reverse
transcribes mrna so it's even
suggestive of a positive feedback
mechanism
now
there are a million possibilities here
right it's likely
that
this never makes it into the germline
right even if it does
get
cut spliced into the genome in the
nuclei of cells in some part of the body
that it never makes it to the germ line
and so it doesn't likely an evolutionary
dead end but that doesn't help the
individual right but i mean i guess the
point is look
a
people have fought over the question and
those on the the vaccine enthusiast side
have crowed endlessly about the fact
that this is not gene therapy because it
does not
it does not touch the uh the nuclear
genome right and you know i i've stayed
out of that because yeah it's not
supposed to
but
so it's it's about
um unintended consequences
and complex systems
and specifically the hyper novelty about
which we go on so much in hunter
gatherer's guide and
with which we are all surrounded really
um and actually i'd love to just circle
back and give you one more example of
exactly that from this transgenic tree
oh great organization
um
the company is called living carbon and
we are told in this piece that's
published in the news branch of science
magazine the journal
living carbon is also trying to engineer
trees to take up heavy metals from
degraded soils
company leaders hope those metals could
give the wood antifungal properties that
will reduce its decomposition rate
enabling it to store carbon longer
that actually makes sense to me it's not
a complete analysis
they're trying to reduce decomp
in the trees they have to
they have to because what they're what
they're arguing and frankly i don't
believe them because they are obviously
victims of this thing that has replaced
science with sales right right but what
they're trying to do what they want to
say is look
the way to reduce global warming in so
much in so far as global warming is the
result of too much of the ratio of
carbon in our atmosphere having gotten
too high right what they need to do
is pull that carbon out of the
atmosphere
in some way and that's worthless if it
gets pulled out and then returned on the
decomposition so basically the point is
but then but then there's the
equilibrium they're acknowledging that
they have no intention of these species
being part of any ecosystem ever
because if they are actually trying to
produce
trees
that grow fast presumably die young and
then lie there forever
not returning their nutrients to the
earth into the nitrogen cycle and you
know everything else
then they become yet another
unforeseen problem in that ecosystem
that they have created and that no one
will know what to do with so you know if
if this is just a product yeah and if
and if they could which of course they
can't but if they could you know
grow it in a
contained manner such that it did not
spread its its genetically modified
seed
who knows i don't know if it's in the
germline although plants not having the
sequestered germline probably it will be
right
um
into outside areas if they if they could
basically
plant these and and have them not
interact in any way with any native
species
it's gonna be i can't imagine they
possibly would and then they're hoping
that it's pulling up heavy metals from
what then
right so they're gonna rope like
it every step you take it falls apart
because they both want it to be part of
the ecosystem so that it's helping
you know mitigate heavy metal toxicity
in soils etc
but also they want to then immediately
you know chop those down and use them in
building materials even though it's
going to be soft wood because it grew so
fast but they don't want that returning
to the to the soil because of the heavy
metals that they were supposedly solving
the problem of i mean it's not that they
haven't identified some real problems
but it's like every analysis stops at
exactly the point like we are told the
analysis stops at exactly the point that
it comes to the conclusion they want and
this is you know this is the game the
cdc plays right the cdc is like oh we
got 19 months worth of data we're going
to show you two weeks right here in a
particular state and that's gonna that's
gonna reveal the pattern we like right
and you know they're just this is what
is happening everywhere pick and choose
the little slice of data that you like
don't actually share the data but be
assured here's a nice graph with you
know maybe even mucked up axes and trust
us we're the science
so
it is the mental disorder called sales
that's what's happening right the mental
disorder called sales is one in which
you don't actually care that your
customer is better off
the important thing you have succeeded
at the point that your customer believes
they will be better off enough that they
buy the thing and what i would argue is
that
we have been running the stupidest gain
of function experiment with respect to
sales in the history of the universe
right we by virtue of the fact that we
have plugged science into the market
right where we have basically said oh
your science is good here convince a
bunch of your peers that your science is
really important so that you win the
funding game right what we do is we
train people who we are supposed to be
we are supposed to be training them to
be totally deaf
to whether or not their conclusions are
good for them
right we want you to put forward a
hypothesis because it needs to be
advanced and then to falsify it and to
feel happy that you shot down your own
hypothesis that's what a good scientist
does right instead what we do is we
train
scientists who may have gone into it
with that instinct we train them
to be salespeople and to lie to each
other right and then we group them into
little clicks where the point is hell
i've got a little lie that i'm going to
include in my grant proposal and then
you can pick up that lie in your grant
proposal and will each you know validate
these lies and the point is how do you
get to a place where the entire
scientific apparatus all
lies in unison in perfect harmony about
the same topic well this is how you do
it well i mean it's and it's even worse
right like but wait there's more right
that you know we know and again deutsch
talks about this in his piece and gold
acre talks about bad pharma and it's you
know it's well it's well understood that
pharmaceutical companies write papers
that come to conclusions that are
favorable to them whether or not they're
freaking true or not and then they get
people
who are assessed on the basis of how
many publications they have
to put their names on those papers and
those people whose names are on papers
they did not write whose data they have
not seen that they cannot vouch for then
get all the spoils of academia they get
the they get more grant money and they
get more advancement within their
university and they get the accolades
and then they get more papers coming to
them that they did not write and cannot
vouch for and probably are not true onto
which they just slap their name and so
it continues right and it is effectively
the
pharmaceutical companies having invaded
academia virus-like and then suddenly
people who look like scientists are
spouting pharma [ __ ] right they're
partially spouting science they're using
the you know the terminology that they
were taught to wield but they are saying
things that are pharma favorable because
it it pays their [ __ ] rent right
right they are effectively infected
cells inside of academia and the problem
is the public has no idea that this is
taking place they've got the elbow
patches so it looks like self
exactly it looks it looks enough
that people buy it and when they say hey
be terrified this terrifying thing is
out there right and you know what here's
the good news the terrifying thing is
coming to get you but it just so happens
that we have the thing that protects you
from the terrifying things so you're
welcome yeah you don't need to be afraid
anymore we did have to skimp a little
bit on the safety but it's for your own
good yep and then and then the craziest
part is you've got
what turns out to be a relatively small
number of people
who are so committed to the science
thing that they will continue to do it
in the face of this sales game yeah and
what has happened to all of us frankly
is we have been demonized and
marginalized and portrayed as crazy and
weird or corrupt or something it's the
exact inverse of the truth and i do want
to point out
if you're interested in that
uh paper the the uh swedish paper on the
um
reverse transcription of the mrna
messages check out dr mobine saeed he's
one of the heroes of
um the kovid pandemic he's got an
excellent series on youtube in which he
explores uh medical questions in depth
rather like um
like john campbell and and others
anyway check out his recent video on the
february 25th um
swedish paper on reverse transcription
uh we will put a link to that
um and i also will put a link to the
paper itself so you can look at it
but you know you've got a small number
of people who are committed to not doing
sales the sales thing has gone after us
right it has
it has gone after us because it cannot
tolerate an encounter with um
frankly the scientific method right and
that i mean this is this is the irony of
the whole thing i'm reminded
i'm reminded of the idiot ecologist and
sorry not all ecologists but this guy
was truly special
who said to me smugly
i used to think hypothesis was important
now i know better
now i know worse
yeah
all right so i wanted i wanted to
connect this i don't know if we were
done with this topic but i wanted to
connect it around and i'd go for it i
don't even think it's a stretch right it
seems like it's a stretch but it's not
okay i want to connect this up to what's
happened in ukraine and i want to say i
want to say up front i'll say i don't
see it yet all right
but you will okay so easily okay here's
the thing first of all i want to confess
up front i know very little about
ukraine and even russia and that's
embarrassing because actually my
ancestry on my father's side largely
comes from ukraine and and russia i
should know more but i don't and i'm not
going to pretend to and there has been
some excellent discussion of late about
um the
reflexive tendency of people especially
on twitter to
feel like they have to say something
about what's taking place in ukraine
because it's the thing of the moment and
so you've got all kinds of people who
should know better who are saying
perfectly stupid things um just so that
they haven't been silent right and so
anyway i want to avoid that trap i don't
feel compelled
you know i am very much a student on the
question of ukraine and i will say um
among the
delightful discoveries of this
horrifying chapter in which realities of
the 20th century that you and i remember
have come rushing back into the 21st
century in a most unwelcome way
one of the great discoveries
is
constantine kissin's excellent
exploration of this he is somebody who
has
relatives he's half of the trigonometry
duo half of trigonometry and there's an
excellent interview where francis
basically interviews constantin who has
constantine who speaks russian who i
believe emigrated from russia has um
family in ukraine both russian
separatist family and russian and uh
ukrainian nationalist
family he's got family members on both
sides of the divide
and anyway he goes through this as
somebody who does understand the deep
issues here and
it's it's an amazing
heartbreaking and very beautiful
exploration of things that does connect
certain dots okay um
one of the things that connects is
something that you and i have been
saying you know obviously we didn't
start in the public eye talking about
covid you and i came to public attention
over the uh early and very dramatic
eruption of wokeness at the college
where we used to teach at evergreen
um
and one of the things that we said very
regularly i ca i mean it must i must
have said it a hundred times is
you can't do this right if you do this
with civilization the ship isn't going
to sink right away yeah but what is
going to happen is you are going to open
the door to every enemy right because
you're too busy fooling around with
phony hazards and all of this other
nonsense and anyway
um
zach will you show
i sent constantine's tweet from i think
this morning can you show that
so in any case while zach is putting
that up i will say
um yeah can you enlarge that
um
constantine's uh
perspective here
is very sobering effectively what he
says is look i told you this was going
to happen it's not it wasn't even
difficult right now what he says in his
tweet this morning is there is a
narrative emerging about people like me
who predicted the russian invasion and
the board and the broader geopolitical
reordering we are now seeing
right
and effectively what he points to is
something you and i find
familiar from this other landscape right
which is people saying okay
you got it right but for the wrong
reasons right
you may have predicted it correctly but
you're still wrong
and to me because we can't afford for
you to be right
or or we can't afford to
embolden you to empower you
it is the thing you're the wrong guy the
sales people this is the thing they fear
most is that history demonstrations he's
the wrong guy now here's where the wrong
guy is it is totally possible to
make a correct prediction for the wrong
reasons sure that happens what is not
possible is a track record
right the more times you make a correct
prediction that other people are not
making the more likely it is that you
have an underlying model that actually
does reveal something about reality that
others are not seeing
so
this idea that people are going to go
after constantine and
he does deliver in this tweet thread
which i encourage people to go look at
evidence that in fact no no no he did
not get this
right by luck right he understood what
was going to happen and why he tried to
warn people and they didn't listen and
now it's happened and his basic points
very sobering in the in the video he and
francis put out
um
he
basically says look
you have brought a particular part of
history to an end through your
indifference you have you have played
around with an essential feature of the
world and now
the predictable collapse has come and
you now live in a different world and
that's your own doing
right and it's i believe completely
accurate but what i want to
to bring these things together
you and i studied biology we studied
evolution
um
that allows us to see certain stuff but
we also studied the philosophy of
science which
you know our audience
i don't know what they think about are
invoking the philosophy of science
but i want to remind people the point is
the philosophy of science is in its own
way
kind of a dry topic
right it doesn't have a lot of punch
it's not like
squirrels and hummingbirds and other fun
stuff right it's dry but the point is
getting the philosophy of science right
is the difference between actually doing
science and doing pseudoscience
and so
what i want to say about
constantine's point here
is that if you got something wrong
and somebody else predicted it correctly
you do not get to raise the objection
that they got it right for the wrong
reason right even if it's true that is
not your place the only people who are
in a position to critique somebody who
predicted correctly are people who also
predicted correctly which is a tiny tiny
subset right so my point is look i'm not
sure i agree with this
really well i think um
i don't like the idea of actually it's
not your place to critique here i
obviously see a ton of bad faith
critique out there yeah a ton and it's
and it
more often than not is actually
destructive of communication
and of um
and of learning what is actually true
um but
i guess at the moment i'm very averse to
any kind of gatekeeping that looks
gameable well i'm not really talking
about gatekeeping i'm not saying if you
got it wrong that you need to not speak
what i'm saying is you are not in a
position to go after somebody who got it
right right you can say look i think
that that was incorrect and here's where
i think the error is it's fine just say
whatever you want
but to actually try to pull the rug out
from under somebody
who correctly predicted
right is
to me it's uh it is a violation of the
underlying philosophy of science where
the real point is look
i don't care who you are i don't care
what degree you do or don't have i don't
care whether you are officially
understood to be
insightful expert or anything what i
care about is whether or not you are
capable of seeing things ahead and if
you are capable of seeing things ahead
in this realm
as far as i'm concerned i'm listening
and if you're not i don't care that you
have the advanced degree and the fancy
position and that you you know show up
in the new york times the point is you
either have predictive power or you
don't and at this moment we ought to be
listening to constantine on the question
of ukraine because he correctly warned
us
that warning was not heated and we now
live in a worse world that could have
been avoided if we did listen
well on that i
agree
and you know one of the things he says
in this video that again we'll link to
um repeatedly is there is an absence of
leadership
there is an absence of leadership and uh
you know he he
not entirely um but
part of his argument is
um
and this is not his language at all but
basically you know i see as i think you
know the entire world understands putin
to be this strong man
and
you know what what does a strong man
respect
is
other people like him and they don't
need to be operating in bad faith or
through through terrible actions but a
strong man respects strength
and is going to respond to strength and
is not going to respond to
to what what we've been doing in the
west
and yes um and you know is not going to
stand down and wait for us to get our
act together before he makes his strong
man bullying horrifying moves on the
planet he's going to take advantage of
the moment when we are
being idiots of course he is right of
course he is and you know of course we
see as of today
military games by china off of taiwan
how how would this not have been the
case and so what we have been doing
in the west is not only not tending our
strength
but we have been broadcasting weakness
we have been broadcasting foolishness
and frivolity and effectively an
autoimmune disorder
and i guess maybe the last thing that i
would want to do today
oh
good
well okay i'll do this last thing and
then we can we can uh move to
to whatever the other thing is
um
is
uh
i have lost my train of thought
oh yeah we're talking about strength and
uh the west
and
i can't get you farther than that um
bad bad news all right you you do your
thing i'll be back with it how about i'm
gonna read this one poem yep and then
maybe you'll maybe you'll come back to
it okay um so we have a
uh
we do have a short letter that we wanted
to to share but also we were sent um we
were sent the piece of wild things by
wendell berry this week by fan
it's wonderful he's
he's wonderful and there are a couple of
there are just several marvelous poems
in here
um
actually two two poems okay
uh
the
eponymous poem of the of the book the
piece of wild things
when despair for the world grows in me
and i wake in the night at the least
sound in fear of what my life and my
children's lives may be
i go and lie down where the wood drake
rests in his beauty on the water and the
great heron feeds
i come into the peace of wild things who
do not tax their lives with forethought
of grief i come into the presence of
still water and i feel above me the day
blind stars waiting with their light
for a time i rest in the grace of the
world
and i'm free
that's one this other one is very very
different
did you remember i did you want to do
that before i read this next one sure
okay
all right
what i wanted to argue is that we've got
a built-in
defect that has caused us to put
our very future in jeopardy and i don't
just mean
the future of the west i mean the future
of the world which is imperiled by the
failure of the west
and the defect is this
all creatures
all products of evolution
seek
opportunity
to
improve something
even a bacterium
is likely only to replace itself in the
world unless it finds an untapped
opportunity right an orange sitting on
the counter
is an untapped opportunity and if a
fungus or a bacterium can find it then
its numbers can grow exponentially and
that population then becomes the basis
for finding the next orange or the
tub of yogurt or whatever
so creatures are looking for
non-zero-sum opportunities
and they are not looking therefore for
things that work really really well
because there's no opportunity in them
if you've got something that's perfect
there's no opportunity for improvement
and so obsessing on it is
a waste of time
now we don't have anything that's
perfect
but what we do have is a system that has
been
spectacular good at being productive
and has been
spectacularly better than everything
that preceded it in distributing
well-being
in a fair way now what i did not say
was that our system is fair
i don't believe it's fair
it's terribly unfair
but it's fairer than anything that has
preceded it and the solution to its
unfairness is to make it fairer than it
is
not
to destroy it
but what i believe has happened
is that very foolish childish people
have obsessed on the degree to which our
system
does not fully succeed
and they have invented
instances in which it is claimed to have
failed when it didn't
and they have used this as an argument
to unmake all of the underlying
structure that actually does work
right and you and i tried to prevent
this we've tried to explain look we're
not saying the system is fair and this
is one of the strengths of liberals is
that we do understand the unfairness of
the system and we aspire to see it
become more fair but we're not naive
liberals we understand that it has
actually done a really good job it has
liberated many people who were not
liberated before and it has been a
beacon of hope for exactly that reason
and so to the extent that it is not as
fair as it might be
let's [ __ ] fix it
right let's make it better but let's not
gamble
on the idea that the unfairness is so
riddled through its core that we have to
destroy it and that something magically
wonderful will replace it that's not
going to happen the chances that
something that replaces it will be
fairer rather than worse are really
really low and in fact you can see that
in
the dual threat of russia and china
waiting for us to be weak enough that
they can
do things in the world they would not
have done before and so
what i'm getting at is that this
bias
in evolved creatures and therefore in
human beings in focusing on that which
doesn't work
because places that something doesn't
work are an opportunity to improve
something
and therefore a bias against looking at
things that do work has caused foolish
people to jeopardize the west having no
idea that every problem that animates
them is likely to get worse if they
succeed they have now put us in that
jeopardy and um
it is so incredibly
naive of them and so not their right
to have done this
that i think many of us who did see this
coming and said so
right
it's not college campuses it's not a
free speech crisis you are making claims
about civilization that are going to
affect our engineering schools and our
medical schools and our
ability to govern based on something
scientifically robust and our public
health response our public health
response our military and you can see it
right if you want
if you want a civilization
in which people are liberated to explore
the possibility that there are 30
genders
right if you want people to explore the
idea that you can
shift your sexual preference with each
day of the week right i don't think
that's smart but if you want a society
that's free enough in which you can
explore that hypothesis and see whether
it turns out to make things better then
what you need is a really [ __ ]
masculine military to guard your borders
so that your enemies don't take
advantage of your little experiment and
instead we did it to the military too
right we basically flung the gates of
the city open to our enemies and
one thing that i think
it's just a hypothesis and i'm not
saying you know to say that it is a
hypothesis is not to say that i believe
it is true right it's to say that it
might be true and i'd like to know
but one possibility is that somehow our
level of stupidity exceeds what could
naturally be explained by confusion that
in fact you know riddled throughout our
technology and our media environment
are components that were built by people
whose interests are not our interests
and maybe our level of stupidity is not
organic
maybe our level of stupidity is not
organic he says he says well i think
that actually
is a good segue for this next wendell
berry poem believe it or not this has
very little in common with that last one
manifesto the mad farmer liberation
oh
front
like this love the quick profit the
annual raise vacation with pay
want more of everything ready made be
afraid to know your neighbors and to die
and you will have a window in your head
not even your future will be a mystery
anymore your mind will be punched in a
card and shut away in a little drawer
when they want you to buy something they
will call you when they want you to die
for profit they will let you know
so friends every day do something that
won't compute
love the lord love the world work for
nothing take all that you have and be
poor love somebody who does not deserve
it denounce the government and embrace
the flag hope to live in that free
republic for which it stands give your
approval to all you cannot understand
praise ignorance for what man has not
encountered he has not destroyed ask the
questions that have no answers invest in
the millennium plant sequoias say that
your main crop is the forest that you
did not plant that you will not live to
harvest say that the leaves are
harvested when they have rotted into the
mold call that profit prophecy such
returns put your faith in the two inches
of humus that will build under the trees
every thousand years
listen to carrion put your ear close and
hear the faint shattering of the songs
that are to come expect the end of the
world laugh laughter is immeasurable be
joyful though you have considered all
the facts
so long as women do not go cheap for
power please women more than men ask
yourself will this satisfy a woman
satisfied to bear a child will this
disturb the sleep of a woman near to
giving birth go with your love to the
fields lie easy in the shade rest your
head in her lap swear allegiance to what
is niest your thoughts as soon as the
generals and the politicos can predict
the motions of your mind lose it leave
it as a sign to mark the false trail the
way you didn't go be like the fox who
makes more tracks than necessary some in
the wrong direction practice
resurrection
holy moly is that a good poem isn't that
that's so good uh what was the line in
there so long as she does not go cheap
more than men yeah uh so long as women
do not go cheap for power please women
more than men oh that is so good and it
is you know uh it's one of these things
where
one of the other things that we say is
that all through all true narratives
must reconcile
and so that is to say that when a poet
is tapped into something deep then it
ought to reconcile with all the stuff we
know from
science and in this case
the thing about the two strategies the
two reproductive strategies of men
versus the one reproductive strategy of
women is that it effectively
um comes closer to synonymizing the
viewpoint of women with the long-term
well-being of your lineage
and so anyway i i feel that this has
been
discovered in that uh in that poem
beautiful yeah
okay um and then
here are some words from a man named
matthew
who uh said that yes we could share them
wonderful um
we get we get notes like this and uh
this one was particularly lovely and
short but
i'll um read it
hi heather i started paying attention to
what you and brett have been talking
about roughly around when the dark horse
podcast began
i had the fortune of attending one of
the speaking events moderated in
vancouver with sam harris and jordan
peterson as well
as code began and both you and brett
question the narrative and the vaccines
i began to lose confidence in both of
you as your views deviated from what we
were being told
now as the narrative perpetuated by
government media and the medical
establishment is crumbling i know both
of you were right and absolutely
courageous to stick to your beliefs and
convictions
i am canadian and i am in absolute
disbelief at what has become of my
country this is written on the 22nd of
february
i also feel the worst is yet to come and
kobud was just the tip of the iceberg
now more than ever sensemakers like you
and brett are critically important and i
am very grateful you are doing what you
do please keep fighting the good fight
matthew
thank you matthew
yeah you have no idea matthew how much a
note like that means um
at some point you and i should
talk a bit about
what it has been like to live in our
shoes
during this and it has been i think
quite different than most people would
expect but one thing
that is very clear is that it is not
easy even if you know you're right right
i don't mean right like in an absolute
sense but you know
right trying to be right and actively
trying to be right and discover where
you're wrong writer every day
right if you do that thing where you
purge the stuff that didn't turn out to
be right and you accumulate stuff that
gives you more predictive power
there is a way in which you are right in
the end
um
but one of the things that's really
difficult is as you do that
to find yourself um
demonized by
the salesman in every discipline
it's a very
awkward and alienating experience and
just simply to hear you know it let's
put it this way in some ways it's a
better letter to receive
than one that says you know i've
believed you all along
right somebody who
went through the process of losing
confidence in us because we were so far
from what the public health narrative
said and then to discover in the end
that actually the public health
narrative
was garbage yeah um
it's very very meaningful so thank you
matthew yeah
um
all right i think i think that's it
uh i forgot to start the hour by saying
that tomorrow is our private q a
patreon which um that was a that was in
a mission
um so yeah to you consider joining us at
my patreon
where every month
we collect questions earlier in the
month those have already been collected
but uh but tomorrow on the last sunday
of the month at 11am pacific we have a
two-hour private q a that's small enough
that we actually can watch the chat and
interact with people in the chat
and it's um
it's it's actually a lot of fun it's fun
it is yeah we really enjoy it
um
you can ask questions for the q a that's
immediately to follow this
as soon as our break is over
at
www.darkcoresubmissions.com we will get
to as many of them as we can we never
get to all of them we don't promise to
do that
logistical questions um
can go to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
but not the questions that that you want
to ask of us again our patreons
are
are open and lively and actually before
we see you again next week brett will
have his uh first two hour conversation
uh in the saturday morning before our
next live stream on your patreon
as well um
maybe that's it
be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
you